what is your advice to anyone who wants
to plan
a road trip of their own because you've
got some really good takeaways
all right first of all and this is a
small one but so important
pack the right snacks healthy snacks so
you're not always tempted to pull off
and get fast food everywhere you go
get them in the basket in the front seat
so their arms reach
yeah i totally hear you out okay um is
there any other tips you would give
about
packing mapping having a plan
being willing to let go of your plans so
you know actually one of the best things
about
the van thing that's emerging the van
scene that's emerging
is that it actually forces you to marie
kondo i can turn that into a verb
it really forces you to think about what
you need you have if this is a
two-person van you bring two forks
two plates you don't pack you don't over
pack you bring just what you need
our advice to people is to pack for a
week-long trip
lay it all out on the floor take half of
it put it back away
pack up the other half put it in your
car or your van and just go
you don't need it all as far as i'm
concerned marie kondo is a verb
and i love that advice because i don't
know if it's a girl thing but
i can totally be accused of over packing
oh yeah
it happens okay so you and your family
plan everything you take care of
everything
so we want to plan a trip for you that
you don't have to think about
one thing everything is dialed in you're
gonna go
to aruba for a six night stay at the
hilton aruba caribbean resort and casino
and enjoy the best one happy island
has to offer i'm talking crystal blue
waters
who just which that just sounds so good
right now warm tropical sun
famous palm trees on the beach and this
time you can fly
yeah my back thanks you
okay good so we're just taking care of
everything like the food the amenities
we're gonna dial it all in
and you just need to kick back relax
and i love this place because i think
there's something for
adults and kids kids don't want to be
bored because it's too grown up
and grown-ups don't want to just go to
kid places all the time so i think this
place is a lovely hybrid
drew i'm crying thank you so much
we really need this thank you thank you
we thought this
was kind of the prize because who
doesn't want to drive you know do a road
trip across the country
this is incredible thank you drew so
much i want your toes
and sand i want you to celebrate all
you've accomplished as parents
and just the awesomeness that you
brought to the show and all the people
that you were so kind enough to deliver
these drew-gooder boxes
and join our local affiliates and
bring goodness literally across the
country
oh drew we would do it again in a
heartbeat it was such an inspiring
trip funny you should say that um i
think we should do this again yeah
we would love to seriously great if
you're seeing this we're in
season two yeah coming up around the
corner so
relax enjoy the summer thank you get
your aruba on and then let's
talk about what we can do next is it
okay if we continue
to sticker bomb in aruba um all i want
you to do is stick a bomb
everywhere that you go um and
can i also just take a ride okay good
because i've been you know looking at
the van
and now i'm gonna ride in it
um i am in the brew van officially
[Music]